dude I'm sitting here trying to have
plans for the episode plans you think
about that you showing up you know I
can't show up at life with plans that's
I that is just trouble waiting to happen
you bring in plans to a life fight new
life makes the plans you show up with
too much plans are you gonna be
disappointed every time you know I got
to stay in that flow I got to stay on
that flow Kane baby you feel me and just
you know just just let the Lord snort me
as he a shower
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from my
[Music]
yeah and my mind is somewhere else but
when I found it
I'll patch up where it's been grown now
I'm just floating on the breeze and I
feel hopeful and like these leaves that
must be cornerstone come on get with me
come on come on we can get the words
wrong
[Music]
for me to slap that pocket Wow Wow
man you know what I'm grateful they let
me use that song that's all I'm taking
the headphones off on this one for now
that is Bishop gun and that is their hit
single shine and man shine your light on
me and that's what I need sometimes just
that warm man that light feels warm done
you got to stay in the warmth you got to
stay in the light you got to be a little
light uh you know a little light a
pillar and you got to go crawling in the
bright parts of the world you got to be
a little light a pillar and you got to
go crawling into the bright parts of the
world and look man let's shine I'll hit
you it's gonna you know it's gonna
literally brush off on us if we crawl in
in the light parts of the world oh man
um good to be here with you guys today
thank you guys for joining me it is it
is uh November 5 in the year 2018 can
you do 2018 we are living in the future
this is somebody's future you realize
that this is somebody's straight-up just
you know their brain outer space they
couldn't fathom 2018 and here we are
here we are living in it and you know
kind of enjoying it and also complaining
about a lot of [ __ ] this episode is
brought to you by grey block pizza grey
block pizza it's uh it's at 1811 Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach in Los
Angeles grey block get that heater baby
and they got a different type of pies in
here and they got some really choice
pies they got the grease in the grecian
grecian they got the deep cheese uh the
Frenchie the Venus and Venus have
spinach sun-dried tomorrow with fiesta
and mozzarella cheese on a tomato sauce
boy and so you know they trying to
really if they giving you the tamata
Anna and the tomato sauce man you know
cuz you got a perv a little to squeeze
that tomorrow out and leave a little bit
of his own you know squirt out on you on
your delectables there so that's
beautiful by them and that's great block
pizza in Los Angeles and that's our
charter sponsor been with us since not
day one but probably day two hundred
happy November I just got back from
Buffalo that be low baby and Buffalo man
it is uh you know it's a you know
Buffalo is that resilient City you know
and they want you know sometimes like
people want to talk about these cities
they fell apart and they don't have
anything left these Midwestern cities
and Buffalo says you know what enough a
low bruh we're coming back we got we got
we got virility bruh we still got a
little bit of um you know we still got a
little bit of nut and are in our nuts in
our nuts in our nuts bag we still got a
little bit of that nuked you know that
bye-bye him and that's Buffalo you know
you see people walking around you see a
guy walking around there he got a
chainsaw with him and he ready to work
you know sometime you used to see maybe
a dude he might have a crate you know a
little bit of a crack pipe or like a you
know a little empty bassinet and he
looking for his son or he looking for
somebody's child a small child to put in
the bassinet but now you see a man
walking around he got a chainsaw you
know he got a um you know he got an idea
for a new app a new mobile app and
that's Buffalo man a resilient City they
got a lot of call centers out there they
got a lot of Vol you know they got you
know they're really bouncing back in a
lot of ways and they but also you know
they have you know its first a lot of
kids like the place uh you know hockey I
saw it's a hockey play so it's become a
real mecca for these like specific
hockey hotels and these on junior
leagues for hockey if you didn't know
that about Buffalo and they will you can
get hockey --is-- up there and hockey's
a sport you know hockey's for people
that are afraid to you know it's for
people that are wood that want a fist
fight but also it's like boxing but
people that are kind of want to be kind
of at least a little bit nice about it
you know like less you know I don't want
to punch you in the face but I will
[ __ ] hit you with this stick and
that's hockey and and it's friend you
know it's very respectable hockey they
do it outdoors on frozen water a lot of
sports they come inside where it's nice
and warm and stuff like that hockey
doesn't do that you know how he doesn't
want to break the furniture nothing like
that hockey once to hockey wants to how
can we'll be outdoors and say hey you
know we're not gonna [ __ ] up the coffee
table we're gonna you know we'll beat
each other outdoors on this frozen water
and it's really risky it's almost a
little bit sensual if you like real you
know ice-cold sensuality then that could
be hockey for you
but I had a nice time in Buffalo man
good people good people came out to the
show we had you know why this dude this
dude little Edward came out and he had
something's wrong with him you know he
very distant bro and he reminded me of
this kid when I was growing up actually
they had a boy in my town um and it was
this little black guy honestly man and
he was small you know he was probably
anywhere from three to five and a half
feet and uh and I think I don't even
know what his name was but you couldn't
really get his name out of him you know
you kind of had but you had you couldn't
cuz here's why you couldn't get his
attention and he seemed really distant
and you had to tap him on the shoulder
four or five times you know and we
called him a little distant daddy and he
seemed you know he just you almost had
to wake him up like he was sleeping
inside of himself you know it would have
been really good if the Lord would have
put like a little doorbell on his
shoulder and you could you know press it
and then he'd go get himself and bring
himself to the forefront of his own
existence because that's how it was
trying to get him you know look distant
daddy couldn't get his attention and you
could do fireworks in front of his face
or do a um and we wouldn't do that I'm
just saying you could do that as a you
know you could put a couple of you know
you know a couple you could put a fox
and heat right out in front of them and
if a fox is in heat I don't if you ever
seen a fox and he but a lot of animals
try to come [ __ ] a fox bro because in
the animal kingdom a fox you know a fox
is like the Pamela Anderson of animals
you know every animal try to come [ __ ] a
fox they got you know birds of fly down
you know you'll see a damn Nightingale
come down with an erection bruh trying
to just park that thing in in the back
of a fox because everything wants to
[ __ ] a fox people don't know that and
these are things that they don't teach
us and there's some time you know long
ago they used to teach children
appropriate [ __ ] they could use in the
world and now what are they teaching
them huh
how to just be egomaniacs how to think
they know it all we need to teach
children good stuff and some of the
things they used to teach us was a fox
and heat that's everybody's treat you
did have animals you see a zebra brush
on that you see a zebra [ __ ] you know
he'll paint a horse or paint don't get
us you know to do his job for the day
and he'll slip out of his own cage and
you try to go [ __ ] a fox that's in heat
and that's just the beauty of a you know
a fox have that is that beautiful of an
animal and I've eaten fox man I was
talking to Jamie uh I was talking to
Jamie Kennedy today in the airport I saw
him did I love seeing Jamie Kennedy man
he makes me laugh he makes me you know
he I can tell that he likes me and he
appreciates me and he respects me and so
it makes me feel you know he makes me
feel like cared about and uh you know so
I like talking to him and you know like
I just trust being around him some
people you know I spend a lot of my life
over the years when I think about it
especially being young in conversations
with people that I didn't really even
trust really just because I wanted their
approval you know and man I wish I
wouldn't have done that you know I think
I did it because I didn't know you know
I felt inferior or I felt you know I
needed that somebody's approval or
something to feel okay you know and I
would just listen and just [ __ ] out
idiots you know were people that I was
afraid of I listen you know I just fear
listening you ever listening out of
sheer fear you're just like I used to be
that nervous kind of child you know like
that a little nervous bad boy like that
you know a good boy really you know just
living through hell man but listening
for heaven you know but I hate it you
know I wish I would have done that and
now it's nice to be able to in my time
these days as an adult to just
acknowledge in my instincts man this
person makes me feel good you
they might not be you know they might
not be everybody's cup of tea or
whatever but it doesn't matter then make
me feel good and so I'm gonna be around
them and talk with them and I'm gonna
reverberate that same vibe you know cuz
I'm that [ __ ] blue meringue dog if
you throwing out some beautiful blooms
at me man you giving me that blooming
energy that bloomin onion dude and I
ain't talking about genitalia I'm
talking about you know heart in pure
emotion bruh top four organs that I
think out of somebody's body first
before I think about genitalia
one heart - mmm brain brain right there
second well you better get your [ __ ]
you better get that heart first brah you
know I'm saying you better get that that
that feeling brain that's what I want
first that that that thicker ticker man
that's a heart your brain is as a
computer we got too many computers in
the world so I go brain a heart I go
heart brain what else maybe
liver cuz kidneys are confusing there's
two of them what the [ __ ] y'all doing
bruh don't say figure it out you expect
us to figure out who's who who's who
what what figure your [ __ ] out make one
kidney the fourth organ lungs
I respect the lungs because their
teamwork organs their team workers lungs
need each other they work together you
know they're like um you know they're
like the Iditarod dogs of the human body
you know I did a raw dogs if they're not
happy if they don't have a teammate a
partner up there you don't see somebody
running doing the Iditarod and the
Iditarod is an Alaskan saw it's
basically a way to get away from your
wife and family for like about a month
in Alaska really and there's people in
Alaska they don't want to be you know
they like having windburn on their face
and do people I mean you'll have a
a man's start out he'll be an Inuit and
by the end he'll be out you it you know
who his whole face will be frozen right
off he look like [ __ ] Michael Jackson
of Alaska
you know Michael elastin and this is a
dangerous sport and you basically drive
across the country let dogs pull you
across the country for I think buried
treasure something I don't know where
the [ __ ] did they pull you I mean you
know dogs do they don't give a [ __ ]
they'll pull you [ __ ] for two months
until they find a newspaper or something
and that's it and you're like damn this
is the Iditarod I thought this was a May
you know I did this whole thing up you
know I just I just lost to a damn sports
section you know they got to uh you know
and you got to show up with real dogs
you got a show with wolves you basically
have to approach some wolves and find
the biggest kind of love wanna see in
the group and hire that one and his
buddy or his sister or whatever don't go
out there with one dog for the Iditarod
nah not anything right I mean that's
worse than human traffic and dude when
you see one dude out there on a you know
it's just some shady [ __ ] you know
some dark-skinned gen out there and he's
[ __ ] got an eye you know a little you
know a bichon out there out in front of
them you're like what the [ __ ] bro no
that ain't a real thing and someone
you'll see a brother out there just
trying to find some chicks you'll see a
brother out there he got you know two
pitbulls out there and he wrote Prancer
on the side of one of them and um and
reindeer on the other one he wrote
reindeer on like dude come out but he's
out there and he got these two ah he'll
be out there and he's just looking
basically for some snow puss bro you
know his brothers go deep to find the
ladies they love ladies and also you can
find who else out there on my did urato
you'll see sometime like there you know
kind of uh you know like a homoerotic
type of man out there with a little b
shun and a bichon cold his [ __ ] he's got
on like nine
suits you know he's got on like a
astronaut helmet the Bichon and he's
pulling this one little you know and the
dude he ain't even paying attention this
guy you know little whatever his name is
[ __ ] a slippery Arthur or whatever it
is dude isn't it he's up there he's on
Grindr he's just playing Grindr the
whole time he's out there just you know
looking for some Eskimos looking for
some of that ice cut you know looking
for some of that icy pop pop pop pop pop
pop pop pop and that's Iditarod anyway
I'm just telling you what the Iditarod
is as people basically looking for
buried treasure and I used dogs to do it
but if you show up to the Iditarod with
only one you know that the good dog them
you know the soft wolves they won't go
hard if they don't have a partner and
that's factual dude that's one of the
facts from a higher power that's not me
I'm not telling you that out of my brain
that's something that's you know from a
higher power and so you can and that's
in the books and everything that's in a
library basically in the library when I
was growing up that was it was like your
dad but it was in a building and and it
man you go in there do it and it's uh
but anyway yeah the lungs the lungs have
to work together so that's the fourth
organ that I respect the most
after that straight-up full body Weiner
that's that fifth organ because the
Weiner you don't really need it until
you ready until you're ready to
procreate because you can just I mean be
honest right you we can just piss out of
a little hole in our body you know we
can just I mean man could have a vagina
if he just took his wiener off and got
very angry sometimes
and you know let mother nature kind of
push his buttons in the background you
know once a month and he also gave
better hugs
and if man could do all of that then
then I think that they could probably if
they were able to take off their wiener
they could be uh they could have a shot
of being a woman but anyhow mmm but what
am I talking about man I never know what
I'm talking about
and then for brief moments I do I guess
but I'm grateful to be here with you
guys man and and I just want to say this
man support the park has so many people
come out and support it continue to
support it and I'm grateful to the
people that have come out you know and I
love I'm grateful to get to go see I get
to go see Buffalo and I see people that
come out man dude they had a guy that
came out and he uh he came out so I
think Thursday or Friday man you could
tell it meant a lot to him you know he's
standing there and he was kind of
tearing up you know and he was like hey
man you know you were you know your
podcast has really meant a lot to me
that's what he told me and I could see
it you know I kept feeling in his face I
could feel in his face man because our
eyes are just you know they're just
they're just wet balls of fear but they
really want to be hugs and I could see
in his eyes you know he had just these
kind of fearful hugs going on at the
same time there's battlers and I get
them you know I get them a lot when
you're you get those battlers man you
know when your eyes are just you know
they just you want to express emotion
you know in this guy he was just feeling
his emotions man and I respected it you
know and uh and he's like hey man I love
you you know I really love you and I
just want to tell that guy you know I
don't know if I got to express to him I
love you too man you know and not you
know I'm not trying to be wild which
you're nothing like that you know I
never you know I've never owned a van or
nothing like that or anything you know
and I babysat overnight everybody knows
that kind of thing about me I'm not
trying to be
which you know my trying to shake your
hand and then keep moving my hand up
your body up your arm and up yeah you
know in the nape of your neck and down
your body like that and next thing you
know I'm introducing myself to your
Weiner and all of that and everything
I'm not doing that
there's a lot of shady men that do that
trust me I live in Los Angeles there you
have no clue how many you know men out
here offering handshakes and really the
whole time made us trying to you know
know how much your balls way so they can
be fancy back at their house and they
want you to see their artwork or
something dude
artwork bro do you think I care about
artwork because if I go looking at it
hard enough you're gonna sneak around
and try to paint a picture your face
down between my booty and so I know
what's going on here some boy trying to
be sneaky and you know everybody's got
their desires but don't sneak them
around on me you know because it's that
kind of stuff happens to men - it's a
dark the dark arts are alive here in Los
Angeles people thinking they can just
buy your way you know aggressively buy
their way
- urine securities it's crazy man now
you know they have the securities
exchange they said of the in securities
exchange because they got a lot of
sneaky men out here and that's dark arts
what was I talking about
yeah my brain is like on a nature trail
my brain today it feels like it's just
running from the police and it's just
gonna you know it's going it's ducking
through the woods this way and through
that way - ever oh sorry but this young
man came out man and uh and it just man
I appreciated it you know cuz for a
second inside of him and he was like
real vulnerable and he was telling me
how he felt and I you know I needed that
you know I needed that to kind of bring
you know place more of vulnerability
sometimes you know cuz that's one thing
I loved about this podcast when it
started and it's gonna get back there
and it is back there it has its moments
you know but there was really you know I
was really you know to be honest I came
to this podcast in the beginning with
some vulnerability I'm just talking
about my life and fear and then and my
fears and then now it's wild because
since there's more listeners I get
afraid sometimes I think - or you know
my ego gets in it I don't know sometimes
if I'm connecting the same way but I
think that there's always going to be a
level of adaptation and you know you
don't realize that you've got to turn
the stove off until yeah until your
house is on fire when your house is on
fire you're like aw [ __ ] I can cut the
stove off because you know this fire is
gonna heat up these you know these
tostadas or whatever I'm making out here
these little wah I like to make
pop-tarts with peanut butter melt it on
but I don't tell anybody
don't tell anybody dude if you tell
anybody I'm gonna be upset but I like to
make those you know I get those
beautiful bright I was like a damn
birthday cake when I was growing up
son of my mom would slip up and she you
know because I grew up in that household
where if they had peanut butter in the
house people were hiding it you know
people I remember they had this board
game about the game Clue and I didn't
understand it people hiding from each
other in a nice house I'm like why are
y'all hiding man y'all should be
enjoying this [ __ ] but then my mom she
put it to me like that she's like well
just pretend it's like somebody in our
house you know when we got a peanut
butter and I was like oh man you don't
know who's got the peanut butter because
you know how somebody would hide the
peanut butter if you had dude when the
peanut butter came out of Mom's thing if
she didn't [ __ ] hide it somebody
better hide Daanish aunt
brother when you were poor peanut butter
the closest thing to a [ __ ] steak
that's a whole you know that's a
40-ounce jaw of filet mignons baby mmm a
spreadable [ __ ] that's that
spreadable uh you know whatever bro
that's that spreadable that's uh that's
that spreadable sirloin that's that
spreadable sirloin peanut butter and you
wouldn't know who had it so you were
constantly like you know quizzing people
smelling people's breath because peanut
butter is that hunt you can't some
things you could hide if you're eating
you could hide the smell if you've had
about 40 dude you could have 50 gummy
bears you sick bastard you eating bears
bro you don't think the gut you don't
think they mother nature's remembering
that [ __ ] and next time you out there
hiking in or gardening you growing a
couple of radishes and Barbra a real
bear gets your ass that's candy karma
son look out you know that's just like
when you have you know you addicted to
butterfingers and you have one of these
Hollywood meetings and [ __ ] you know
some soft boss out here gives you that
captain Lou albano or something and
you're like whoa whoa what was I talking
about Oh oh man I was enjoying what I
was talking about too
[Music]
let me see what I was talking about I
know what I was talking about dude cuz
I'm going back in time in my head my
brain is slow like that dude my brain
it's like a um my brain sometimes this
feels like a I don't know if it feels
like it's running from something or
running towards something you know what
that's actually kind of an interesting
question is to ask ourselves you know do
we feel like we are running from
something or moving for a way from
something or toward something in our
life and if one is
than the other you know or if I'm just
thinking out loud here if I'm not sorry
I'm thinking about out loud that's what
this whole podcast is for for me to
think out loud man but um but yeah I'm
like I'm wondering like I'm trying to
get that feeling in me in my life am i
running from am i moving towards
something or am i moving away from
something and then if I am is one of
them by like am i running from something
or am i running towards something like
if you're running towards something
there's excitement if you're running
from something there's fear so I'm just
I'm just wondering which one it is and
maybe we'll call that run during
sometimes are under do this that's kind
of crazy that's kind of neat now we just
thought that up together I'm wondering
which is what am I good where am I going
am I going towards something right now
I'm going from something it's something
pulling me it's something pushing me am
i moving at my own will am i moving my
choice or my fear what's is there
something in front of me something
behind me where's my Gepetto at you know
where's the strings what's going on here
with me and I think at the beginning you
know and and I keep talking about this
podcast like you know because here's the
thing I feel like this could the
community in this podcast is a good
opportunity I noticed that I'd notice a
good opportunity my whole life and when
I see groups of people coming out to
these shows man it's people that are
loving people I mean loving people in
the world and I know that we are
building a neat community and I don't
mean that I'm building it because even
just like on that run during idea some
people like oh it's a stupid idea they
shut the show off that's fine but I
couldn't come up with the idea I
couldn't help come up with the idea if
you guys weren't listening they're with
me and being a safe place for me to
think and feel
said that in the world today do people
can't even have a thought or feeling
without feeling they're gonna lose their
job you know or the feeling they're
gonna lose their voice dude how many
people during the election afraid to
probably vote or think or ask a question
because they feel that their boss will
fire them or they'd be unwelcome in
their neighborhood or their apartment
building you know and I'm not making a
political men but I'm just you know I'm
trying to think of things where you know
people where we just feel like we can't
do something um yeah I don't know where
my train of thought is just my train of
thought is just I don't know we left the
station or somewhere it's lost if you
see a train in your local area on the
street then you know it could be it
could be an idea that I had the other
day or today right now they just left
and landed somewhere out by you but yeah
I was just like just about you know
getting back to the guy that came out it
was just like you know it was just nice
man it's nice to see emotions I feel
like emotions are gonna be something's
gonna be in a museum one day you know
and that's why sometimes I'm like we
live in this time are we scared even
have emotions of these little baby bears
that are climbing around our rib cage
always you know emotions are these
beautiful little tricksters you know
they're doing handstands and some of the
bears are hiding behind the cage and you
know some of them there's always a
couple of bears down by the bottom ribs
you know one of them's got his face
painted up like Marilyn Manson's and
they you know touching a little you know
they touching their little candy sticks
you know but but bears are you know our
feelings are like these little bears
that are just climbing around on our
ribcage and this is all this is their
you know this is their monkey bars and
our feelings used to be more like
monkeys you know and they were more like
primal kind of you know and now they're
more like bear bars you know our
feelings are a little
softer sometimes in people sensitive and
the bear will slip off the bars and fall
down into a lawsuit you know but it's
like you know our rib cages are like
monkey bars for our emotions and and I
don't want our emotions to be something
that disappear from the world and
technology is something that takes those
but we have to just you know but we have
to work with it so I think sometimes
they should have laws on how much
technology there can be people like
that's crazy that's not crazy there's
laws on how much cocaine you can do and
drive around yeah they won't allow any
which I think it might be a little off
you know I'm saying so now I'm a little
pop will help you get you know help you
get through like traffic if you feel me
but if you out there just you know
dusting yourself off you know if you out
there just [ __ ] doing drywall and
you're in own interior you know you
serving your brain just [ __ ] desert
dunes then you gonna that's not safe but
is technology this [ __ ] is a hell of a
drug dude I saw a kid the other day I
talked to him for 40 minutes he didn't
even know I was there he didn't know I
was there I do impersonate a pop-up
advertisement to even get his attention
for a second and then he just like kind
of it's like they had an X right here
and he just kind of pressed it by my
head like Jesus Christ just a different
time but yeah I think our rib cages are
like these these places you know they're
they used to be monkey bars for our
feelings and then that and I saw respect
that when I see an emotion when somebody
that's real you know I'm kind of a
romanticist I guess and that sense I'm
kind of a traditionalist and I love
those things man and so I love the fact
when anybody's brave enough to share
some thoughts or some real emotions and
I'm that's what I you know that's one
thing that I love and note those are the
types of things those people that come
out to our shows
you know they're real there's a lot of
emotional just real people and I love
that man I appreciate it we had some
some police officers came out up from
miami-dade bruh I respect those guys
they came out everybody's always hard on
the police the police do these aren't
dudes dudes aren't scientists they're
out there [ __ ] fighting bad guys and
doing the best they can you go fight a
[ __ ] bad guy you can't you afraid to
even you know give you a 13 year old son
of spanking you can't even watch the
Daniel Cormier fight you know shot out
Louisiana you can't even watch that
without you know making sure your doors
are locked I can anyway and then here I
got and I'm gonna sit there and tweet
about cops are complaining about cops
[ __ ] anybody that's complaining about
[ __ ] on Twitter man and if I do it [ __ ]
me [ __ ] me as well a bunch of wimps you
know a bunch of freaking wimps the world
gets better we get out and make it
better man and and good people are
coming out to these shows and sorry I'm
getting agitated about that but I really
feel that and we're gonna do some cool
stuff together as a group as time goes
on and that's one thing that I love
about this podcast group it's not just a
you know I think and I don't I'm not
trying to sound ego egotistical you know
I feel like we're just create and so
many people send me messages and emails
and just say nice things did I get here
up what one day we'll go to a couple
voicemails I get like 50 of these a day
man in some facet I'm not joking bro
it's Brian down in South Florida I was
just listening to your podcast and you
were in South Florida dude that's
basically a hurricane that's that's a
hurricane that's basically a summer
that's a summer that is a that's
Martha's Vineyard for hurricanes when
hurricanes are hatched out and wherever
wherever they hatch them out they're
Voldemort or the Middle East or whatever
you know they're making these things out
in the Middle East
hurricanes look where they come from
every time right over there
right for us they they're manufacturing
these things and then they might you
know and then they're doing all these
insurance claims and [ __ ] let's liven up
that s but uh thank you for calling man
and thank you for being alive still if
you live in South Florida ah we're
talking about this time of year and kind
of new beginnings
and I just wanted to let you know man
yesterday I went to court and they let
me off of probation yes what I'm saying
boy we got him off who is this dude
again oh sorry man let me go back and
listen from the beginning sorry
what's up Co it's Brian down in South
Florida Brian not guilty not guilty what
do you even do just listening to your
podcast and you were talking about this
time of year and kind of new beginnings
and I just wanted to let you know man
yesterday I went to court and they let
me offer probation your boy is free
after a whole year and they even wiped
my record clean so I feel like I got a
fresh start and I just wanted to really
thank you because it was a hard year and
every Monday you kind of kept me up and
then on Thursday you kind of got me
through the end of the weekend you
really helped me out and I'm going to
take this opportunity with a clean slate
to just kind of live for my new daughter
and for myself and for my family and I
just want to thank you you know you
helped a lot of people Gang Gang Papa
you know I appreciate I appreciate the
nice words man do you help a lot of
people by sharing that story that's what
I'm this isn't a perfect example do
we're just little share bears you know
we're just little share bears out here
crawling around the ribcage looking for
some real feelings and ninh yeah boy
Wayne
Brian okay free Brian let's do it we'll
even know what he did he might looking
you know - Oh Brian's cousins might be
missing we don't know we don't know
what's going on he gets to spend time
with his daughter we don't know
but but we appreciate that he shows up
and he comes in on Monday and this is
what we're a part of because by people
listen and that's how I'm here I come on
you know and so it's a team effort
that's what I feel like I really really
do feel that way you know yeah everybody
wants to listenership for the shows and
they want people to you know tune in and
stuff like that and I yes I've always
wanted that but the show's grown it's
grown man it's grown um hey we're gonna
have the listenership you know and now
it's just like what do we do with it as
a community because we can do some cool
stuff down the road as a group we can do
cool stuff in different communities and
all types of stuff like that but dude
thank you Brian for being a part of it
and get out there and take your girl to
do something you know maybe buy your
girl a little whoa you know with
something special get her a little um a
shovel or something teach you to how to
look for treasure because you do that
man you gotta you teach a little
daughter to look for treasure and not
not out here in the world by chasing me
being a gold digger but you give get you
know you know what they say show a woman
ah um uh uh a rich old dude and now we
eat for a month but give a woman an arm
a metal detector and that [ __ ] will
seek out her own future and uh and
that's what I'm saying man I wish we had
a like a cute little shovel we can even
mail you know to you to give to your
daughter as a gift because you know I
respect a hard-working woman more than
anything and I hope you raise one of
those ma'am because life is about hard
work bro and I'm out here and I'm
[ __ ] feeling soft a lot of times but
sometimes I feel a little bit proud of
myself and uh and I don't know ma'am my
brains all over the place today but I'm
grateful to be here and being a safe
place where I can share it because these
days people can't do it anymore and
we're lucky and this that's what we're
keeping here baby this is the [ __ ]
high of son this is a high bro
Akira screw heroes up in here you know
I know son some of that [ __ ] sounds
crazy and stuff but I feel like we can
do some cool [ __ ] you know and I'm a and
I'm not gonna be ashamed to feel hopeful
this is a high of a [ __ ] hopeful B's
bruh and we're gonna every now and then
we're gonna sneak over and spank Ryan in
showers Brandon a burn and shelves but
thank you for that call mani you're
welcome dude you're welcome and thank
you for showing up every single week
that's what I got let's take another
call that came in here the hotline is
always as nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and I want to let
you know I'm grateful that remember we
did man up a while back and we had Josh
and a few other guys that came on you
know Bobby Lee came on as a guest on an
episode and next thing you know we made
three episodes for Comedy Central well
now Comedy Central wants to make a pilot
of the show and so now they are we're
gonna do it again so if you have you
know if you're struggling you're a man
that's struggling with something real
I'm not trying to take advantage of your
situation this is you know obviously
genuine I want to be able to you know
offer an experience that could be
helpful but you live in Los Angeles or
it's somewhere in America and you think
it could be a good fit for this you know
hit us up drop us a call nine eighty
five six six four nine five zero three
and leave us a voicemail now with that
said that is if you're also a guy who
doesn't want to have anything to do with
that and just wants to share what's
going on in his week or a struggling
with something or young lady you can hit
the hotline as well you know or a young
lady that might have an eye you know for
the show or not for the show but you can
hit the hotline as well and and that's
always a safe space first as a safe
place first you know in a secondarily
this is something we're gonna do and I'm
excited about it you know it's like you
know and I've had different thoughts
over the years about Hollywood and you
know how have you know felt unwelcome
here at times and stuff like that but
but here's the thing about the world is
men you have to meet the world where
it's at
you know and sometimes and sometimes
things will adjust and sometimes you
will adjust but you can't if you walk if
I'm walking around all that if I'm
walking I'm saying you and I'm sorry if
I started to say that recently and
that's when I know I'm getting too into
my own world and I need I need to go to
more meetings and connect with more
humans when I start seeing you instead
of saying you know we or when I start
pointing at somebody and not pointing
myself you know cuz nobody should do
anything you know why cuz nobody's gonna
do anything that I want because I don't
know what I want
a lot of this shit's in my head only I
know what's going on with me and and I
got to come at the world you know and I
have to meet the world where it's at if
you're sitting around bitching about the
way something is but you're so far off
in a different direction that if you're
never gonna be able to associate there
or work there you know it's like if you
were live in Alaska were you waiting to
[ __ ] catch some sunshine and you just
sitting by your window all day and you
got your tanning oil and he got a couple
of like a cigarette she stole maybe from
your stepmother or something you know
cuz she's fully Italian huh and full of
full Italian dude they born with a
cigarette in the back of the throat you
know they gotta you know they got all
kind of nice stuff at the house usually
a little pack of all missed it you know
um Virginia Slims and uh and you know
black olives those little cans of black
olives dude
a full Italian woman they'll keep a
couple black olives and I'm in a
brassiere bra you know no joke would you
pull a bra off and you think it's
nipples and they're like I know it's an
old Italian you know joke these are two
black olives and she hand you morning
you have y'all have a little snack
before y'all get into a little breast
play or something you know a little long
you chew aliy agreeable breasts play am
I talking about doing something deviant
you know the same me too
this is meatlovers you know I'm saying
this is Italian but uh sorry see some of
my brain goes on those tangents and and
I can't get back to what my thoughts are
you know that's like yeah if you waiting
for the sunshine in in a light in Alaska
and you sit by DOE and you just the
whole life you're complaining I ain't on
that oh well at some point you got to go
down there with a [ __ ] and tell them
you love sunshine and then they might be
like oh we didn't know anybody like
sunshine here we thought people just
like the wind burn on their face like
that dude I was talking about earlier
some of those dudes you know they'll
burn their whole [ __ ] face off they
got a dude you know and you went in out
you it and if you're getting in then
they you know William H faci next you
know they got nine [ __ ] faces on and
they running around town but what I'm
saying is you got to meet the world
where it's at you have to meet the world
where it's at man the world is in one
place you're in another place you got to
meet the world where it's at and and I'm
excited that we're gonna be able to do
something great with a man up in this
past weekend and and we're gonna be able
to help out people that you know that uh
can use some you know some extra her own
just like myself because I need it
constantly and and I go out and find
places to get it constantly and one of
the places that I get it is right here
with you guys and sound grateful to that
and I'm grateful for this opportunity in
my life in our lifes man this is going
to be dude what if we get to have a real
show where every week we take you know
we take somebody from that were you know
that wants to be a part of the podcast
and wants to inspire others and we get
out there make something cool with them
dude to be able to help somebody in real
time that's really cool and I know we're
already doing that you might say we're
already doing that you're selling out
this sort of thing but it's not you know
I'm saying I trust my instincts on
things and I trust my instincts on this
you know and I'm excited about this
pilot and I'm excited about the
opportunity because we've done it a few
times and we've proven we have a track
record that there's genuine genuine any
there's genuinity in it that people's
doing genuine good stuff
let's get through a couple of calls here
oh let's take this call right here
here we go hey mr. physical just for
welcome Houston Texas hey Doc I wanted
to give you my Halloween story okay and
Halloween is over now and I appreciate
you calling because you know how much I
enjoyed it and then I love Halloween my
god dude I mean I just was at the house
today just putting away about 40 damn
witch outfits and you know and dude none
of his mine so who knows what I'm
probably gonna get arrested for homeward
treating without your kids oh you got
two kids you bounced out twice I respect
that man that's that full body batch you
know homework and first of all just lazy
[ __ ] raining outside got to
state the anthoula stop by and let the
kids you know jump on in
jump on out oh yeah that was us bruh but
mom had us not only driving but the
station wagon thing down so not only
movie get back on it wasn't in we were
just standing on the tailgate getting
wet just drenched his [ __ ] dude just
jumping off into the Mekong Delta
onward get get out get wet let's do it
let's have fun anyway so to the main
story so my kids going to this knock on
this door and I'm talking to old lady in
my daughter walks back and she doesn't
say no seems kind of scared and I asked
her the only what's wrong and she
doesn't say no when that's Halloween man
children get scared of all kind of [ __ ]
you know you hear a fart during
Halloween and you think it's you know
your great-grandfather's coming around
looking for bread in the kitchen or
something
homework my son is still by the door and
I see a guy Peters head through the door
so I walk up there in a hurry up they
know what's going on what's doing first
of all this gentleman doesn't have a
shirt on man turn the [ __ ] door like
goddamn creeper you know this is 50/50
on this one man because you know dude
should somebody have to wear a shirt
just because your kid wants some [ __ ]
candy that's the question
your kids getting
[ __ ] you know maybe the guy should be
able to serve it at her every once now I
think he should at least have a vest on
I know that for a fact if I'm giving
anything to a child bra very least I
ain't you know maybe I'll show one of my
nipples times has changed when I was
young you could you know show both you
black olives to a little kid it didn't
[ __ ] matter you know you did what you
want but now everybody you know people
sensitive to see in other people's black
olives so a shirtless man I got to hear
more about this let's go
indoor like goddamn creeper and hands my
son two cans of [ __ ] ravioli first of
all I think I need to do a better
parenting job on my son because his
those dumb ass and standing there for
some [ __ ] ravioli but my daughter's
smart enough to get the [ __ ] out of it
oh dude - can of raviolis brah
that's called an Italian hit-and-run
dude if somebody don't care about you
knowing they're Italian they don't stay
they don't invite you to cook but
they'll [ __ ] hit you with those you
know gene and will hit you with two cans
of raviolis and they out
that's not Italian hit and run said he
might have known your boy wasn't you
know didn't have like a real tongue for
foods I'm guessing maybe they thought
that your boy didn't really have a
strong tongue for food you know and so
they're looking at him maybe he needs to
kind of they were thinking that but yeah
your boy took them snacks your girl got
out of there girls no the women are drug
dogs basically they know what's going on
women know it's seven or eight years old
if your marriage is even gonna work if
their spouse is out there you want to
know your marriage is gonna go work go
ask your [ __ ] seven-year-old they'll
tell you right now you're paying all
this money for a therapy you got a
crystal ball right there in the back
room doing arts and crafts by herself
and making homemade purses and [ __ ] and
making dream catchers
you know making all these you know you
know these Ariana you know Pete Davidson
mood ring dreamcatchers or something you
know I don't see how happy Davidson
doesn't come out with a mood ring you
know he basically was ariana grande's
mood ring I've said it you know every
however she was feeling he would dye his
hair and I love that you look at Pete's
head you'd be like oh wow well I guess
she's approachable today but you know
you're kids yet door to door I love it
man your kid learns a lot because here's
the thing I've been a kid right there
and somebody handing you can goods and
in turn of a shirt on I've been that kid
and you learn a lot man you see a lot
right there you see something you don't
want to be you know where maybe you see
something you do you also see somebody
giving food to somebody else there's
something beautiful about it somebody
handing you a couple of you know
consumable treats you ain't got to do
nothing it's kind of beautiful you know
um but yeah maybe look for the good and
look for the positivity in it when else
is just you know the only way you're
gonna get to canned goods out of a dude
with no shirt on and be able to see that
live in real life I'm guessing probably
a food drive after a University of
Kentucky win after University Kentucky
football win but not in the city limits
not in Lexington where you get to go
outside of the city limits for really
really to see that so that's what you're
looking at that's after a church food
drive
but yeah you got to be careful they got
pedophiles out there they got pedophiles
peda feels you know pet of fear it's a
lot of dudes or even afraid of kids
that's what I have I'm a pedophile I'm
afraid these days to be around children
unless it's mon nieces and nephews and i
get in them we wrestling everybody's
legitimate you know nobody's doing
anything sneaky or trying to look at
each other's body or even do it I don't
look at them from the shoulder to the
kneecap son I'm not related to that
child
you know I'm not related to that visual
area I keep it shoulders and up and
knees down and you know I'm a good owner
that's how I do it but I have pet a fear
now I'm ped of fear is just being like
I'll see somebody with a cute kid or
something I'm like I want to say hey
that's a you know you have a beautiful
child there you have a very free your
child was very nice he you know he
bumped into me but he said excuse me or
something or we saw someone struggling
and I you know and he helped him out and
i catched it but the parent didn't see
it and I'll be like you I can't say
anything man they might think I'm the
bad one let's take some other colored
man here we go thank you for calling
about the Halloween man and thank you
for taking your kids trick-or-treating
even in the rain those are beautiful
memories you know one thing that would
be cool is maybe your kid goes to the
door you duck off getting a scary outfit
with like a little hat chat or something
you know one of those little native
choppers bra and then they come back and
they're looking for you and you [ __ ]
they don't know your net you know that I
know what you did last Sioux Falls
outfit you know that big yellow raincoat
with that little native hand hitter run
at hatchette thanks for calling let's
take another call hey Theo what's up
this is Blake from Atlanta
what's up Blake over there in Atlanta
onward
I guess I'm sort of what you would call
a kind of a newer listener to your show
but I love your show okay
escuchen nuevo Papa Mia Manito swallow
and I thought I felt like I had to get
something I've talked I was thinking
about something it is Halloween tomorrow
for me it's Halloween tomorrow and for
the rest of the world and yeah man
Halloween that's you know everybody's
doing the same time you know you know
and I respect you as a as a person you
know you don't get your own Halloween I
guess if you want to you do if you own a
wishing well or something like that then
you probably could do it whenever you
know if you got one of those you know
those baby gateways in the backyard that
goes to the you know the nethers world
in that you know that little [ __ ]
Narnia outburst you know that little
you know that little shawshank retention
you know if you got that little back
thing that goes into a dirty pond out
back to your place you know that magic
that wish them well and you could jump
in and out and you know and just get all
Andy Dufresne up in your brain you can
do that make your own Halloween but but
yeah let's hear more homeward you know
I'm feeling kind of Halloweeny and it's
also almost November so I'm also feeling
kind of Thanksgiving and I was thinking
about pies I've been thinking about
pumpkin pies and I was thinking about uh
you know pecan pie because I've heard it
both of those pies oh yeah man and I
know you I love pie and I don't know if
you knew that or not before you called
the man I love pie cuz a pie is just a
pie just looks up at a cake and is like
hey look at all the [ __ ] beautiful
[ __ ] I did in just an inch-and-a-half
[ __ ] you up there it's like
watching a Mexican dude do well in
basketball that's a pie and he lookin up
all that era T's all these cakes all
these German chocolate hitters six story
nine story they got gyro players he's
you know tiramisu hitting them from the
threes and net and doing them baby Gator
shots and all of that [ __ ] off the back
top and then they got ya bowline little
egg butter you know
ectopy so you know bro and he's that pie
baby and he gets it all done at the
bottom of the bowl and I respect that
100% I love pies and not a high I'm just
a shocked you even knew that I was
thinking about him as much because it's
so crazy soon as Halloween once that
pumpkin strikes midnight and Cinderella
gets out that [ __ ] I got pie in my sky
baby let's hear more so you've heard of
pumpkin pies and you've heard of pecan
pies but what but I've never heard of
pumpkin pie
that's something I've never heard of
what do you mean and not be right
a little half-and-half pumpkin pie half
pumpkin has to go no I wasn't thinking
about that pie and I was thinking is
that something that you would be
interested in is that something that you
would try or you more like a pie
traditionalist and you don't think that
we need to be Mel doing different types
of pies so thank you for taking my call
and a happy Halloween oh man I think
you're on to something that pump can huh
and that's uplifting too cuz pump can do
that's Ken that means anybody you know
you have a piece of pie next thing you
know you you know you and your cousin
[ __ ] Cheryl whipped cream you know
you sharing the toppings on each other
and that's pumpkin butt pump can now you
and your cousins starting a small
business and I love that that pumpkin
pecan boom boom that's a diversity you
know I like that a little did you know
that that little pie that pie movement
yeah I love pause man and you know you
know it's funny now that you say it I do
need a branch out because I've been so
convicted to Apple and I've been so
convicted I'll [ __ ] do you show me a
peach dude I swear to God you showed me
a peach cobbler you how to peach cobbler
in the woods maybe I would say up to 60
feet off the interstate even behind a
couple trees and I'll still be able to
see that [ __ ] driving at 65 miles an
hour I will still be able to see that
thing boy my eyes are keen to a cobbler
baby I got that cobble wobble at my face
son you know I'm saying I see a dessert
enough you know I just can't even handle
myself I see a cobbler even dude gas
station I'll be out full tank brah I'll
be driving by it I don't need any gas I
see peach cobbler 2:15 a quarter pound
brah dude this thing ain't even a tests
on this [ __ ] doing automatic you
times I'll be you toning up in that add
gas iron I'm pumping gas the tank is
full bruh I'm filling the back seat up
with gas I don't give a [ __ ] I want an
excuse to get dad
and that's that caller uh do my neck
goes limp around a cobbler I can't dude
I gotta have to - you know - shorties -
beautiful little southern you know
little biscuit babies in there - hold me
up while I order it
cuz I'm on my neck goes and limp around
a cobbler cuz a cobbler they basically
just took a peach pie put that [ __ ] in
the streets for a few weeks and taught
that thing how to twerk baby and that's
a cobbler boy and I do that Cabo Wabo
I'm a cobbler son I'm fitting shoes for
my sweet tooth son
I love cobbler but yeah I appreciate you
calling about that let's take another
couple calls that have come in here man
you know last week I shared about uh
about you you know um about some
different issues that I was having at
the urinal because I'm that urinal you
know I kind of turned into that a little
baby uh you know I'm really like a
seahorse at a urinal you ever going you
ever try to look for a seahorse
underwater you could barely see them
because they galloped off and they shot
like that and that's how my bladder is
my bladder is like this my bladder is
like a you know my there's this nervous
connection between my brain and my in my
wiener and it's like a still lake and if
one thing upsets that surface man makes
me nervous and then it's just that
ripple just goes and goes and goes and
man I just there's such an uncomfortable
of an idea of discomfort or anything or
negative thought or something model no
uncertainty anxiety gets in and then I'm
standing at the urinal and I'm not even
peeing anymore I'm just somebody that's
you know I'm somebody this has been
holding onto their penis for like three
or four minutes while other people are
peeing and I guess sad about it man I
get you know makes me nervous and us you
know I shared about that on last week's
episode and so you know I went to one
who some people called in about that hey
Theo this is Jess in the Twin Cities in
the Twin Cities he's talking about
Minneapolis and st. Paul
he's not talking you know I don't
anybody thinking there's like a magical
place where twins go live at or
something you know there's not like you
know like look-alike Nevada or some [ __ ]
he's talking about Minneapolis and st.
Paul and I think it was founded by men
there were I don't they were identical
twins but they said they were it could
have been us some type of Ponzi scheme
but let's hear more I heard you're on
your podcast when your urine kind of
locked up on you when we were at the
bathroom I've got I got I got a tip for
you on that and it works it works every
time for me when that happens oh wow
this is interesting so you got that uh
you got to pop a lock on the u-lock here
cuz yeah man once I hit that nerves then
I'm just basically straining my whole
body is straining and I can't have no
feelings in my wiener or in my wiener
area homeward and I heard this on a
Henry Rollins video so this is you know
he's in it he's in a lot of public
urinals so this is like tested and stuff
oh yeah he looks like a guy who's just
spent his whole life just pissing in
Berlin you know he's been real through
some real you know right there on that
mason-dixon line in Berlin he's been a
real you know he's been on the real just
front streets a bit of you know urine
issues homework not you know science I
think um but what I do is when I can't
go I start doing the multiplication
tables in my head like 2 times 2 is 4 4
times 2 is 8 I swear by the time I'm at
like 16 and 32 it's it's it's going you
know and it just starts no matter what
so you might want to give that a try
that happens again so you know good luck
you love the show see you later all
right that's cool man I like that I like
that I'll try that 2 times 2 is 4 2
times 4 is 8 2 times 8 is 16 you know
the problem is it gets tricky after that
you don't want to be the dude at the
urinal [ __ ] just nudge and some
brother you know or some little you know
a guy next to you you know well you know
beautiful Laotian gentleman or something
and saying hey buddy you know what 2
times 16 is because in some areas
you know out there in math Laham or
wherever if people you know if they you
know if they have like a lot of
homoerotic men and they like to do math
and they do might think you're trying to
duck off or something with them and
maybe that's fine if that's what you're
looking to do you're trying to go slow
look and add each other up in a you know
just multiply each other's bodies in
your mouths and all that happen you can
do it but yeah but I but I'll try it and
I appreciate that you know I appreciate
you calling and saying you know this is
a way that you can try it - Tom - is for
- time for 8 2 times 8 16 yeah because I
guess it maybe takes your brain into a
different directions you're not feeling
your anxiety and part of it these days
man you we just got to take our brains
in different direction and some of that
direction is movement movement will get
you going the problem being in a urinal
you stalled out they don't have these
running urinals where you can run and
piss at the same time you know that last
of the Mohicans
you know leakin I could do that right I
like oh you run running run with a spear
MA my hand jump off a cliff piss at the
same time how is that not an Olympic
sport dude we got this [ __ ] ass type
people jumping over hurdles who gives a
[ __ ] dude
do something that's really an Olympian
could do I don't see somebody jumping
over hurdles and that's not even an
Olympian anymore that's just a night
that's an advertisement for a company
now I want to see that real hitter I
want to see somebody you know you know
catching a violent sheep or something
and strangling that thing you know at
the same time that he's aw you know that
he's armed doing a backflip off of off
of a you know a third-story burning
building over there outside of Toledo
now we're talkin that's the [ __ ]
Olympics get this other [ __ ] out of here
but I'll try the multiplication let's
hear because multiplication to divide my
problems I like it homework hey what's
up - yo its gunther from ontario canada
toronto more specifically i turned on
your podcast right and you started
talking about that that nervous pee game
and I just wanted to let you know
that I also suffer that affliction I
also struggle to piss in public I
believe it started when I was about 10
or 11 I remember distinctly I was at a
big football game with my my dad and we
went to use the urinals during halftime
and there is a big line oh my god
the line is the worst because did the
line is the worst when you if you know
you're not going to be able to pee or
the line is though if you already know
that now if you don't know that the line
is the worst anyway the urinal because
now I'll take everybody's waiting
everybody you know you're supposed to be
like the Mark Spitz a piss or something
ready um you know you know not uh you
know who somebody that did something
real fast dude and it was a bunch of
[ __ ] you know so uh I'm trying to
think of somebody like that um you know
it was like uh I want to say Lane Kiffin
but I don't think that's the right guy
but yeah just some you know you're
somebody that [ __ ] fake didn't got it
done and then anyway I'm gonna quit
interrupting you man homework of
grown-ass men behind me and it made me
nervous and my dick just seized up and
I'm 23 now and it's it's been that way
ever since Wow onward it's very bizarre
but these days sometimes what I do is I
go into a stall and sit down and piss oh
yeah
and that probably sounds absolutely
absurd but like you already stated the
alternative is standing at a urinal with
your dick in your hands for three
minutes and then shaking a dried dick
and walking away I figure it's the
lesser of two evils to sit down and piss
ya cuz then you're just like you know
you're acting you're not you didn't
really do that and that crazy then
you're acting
you pissed your [ __ ] Joe Pesci you
know you're pretending you pissed
shaking it off do trying to oh you you
know just saying things like oh that was
a lot you know things like that to make
it seem like you did a lot of urine and
the whole time you got nothing you got
that dry a little you know that little
cat's yawn down there and it's like a
third you know in a cat by the second
yawn I things dry as hell you could
raise cotton in between its teeth but
man
scary dude homework but it is it is
humiliating and it is an affliction
anyways I appreciate you and I
appreciate the podcast and everything
you're doing here love the community and
yeah keep on keepin on gang gang gang
gang papa and look I'll be honest with
you man when I get up at night sometimes
because my urine you know I got a urine
or my wiener has some type of damn you
know I think diverticulitis or something
just the urine gets diverted right out
the gate and I'm pissing on something I
water a plant you know what I'm saying
I'll [ __ ] breastfeed a you know a
breastfeed to Chihuahua across the
street I'm [ __ ] blowing streams you
know just like a you know like kind of a
cheap shower head or something
if you ever stayed at a place that you
know you got to bring you own shower
head when I was growing up they had a
motel when we would drive up to Memphis
they had a motel and you had to bring
you own shower head in there and for two
dollars he had unlocked the water and
you could hook your shower head on there
and do you know do your clean and her
water your plants in the bathroom or
whatever and so we would go in there and
but that thing was a piece of [ __ ] you
know that thing blowing everywhere I
mean basically this thing it really
didn't give you a shower basically
ruined the drywall at a [ __ ]
apartment uh uh of the motel I don't
even think when I really think back on
it that thing was just a scam probably
to collect insurance money or to accuse
somebody of something or they probably
sold them in an area some some company
probably bought all the apartments and
motels in an area you know and then they
had and then they had you know they
bring you
you know you get in there and they made
all the showerheads in the area and sold
them at stores so then people got the
shower heads came in a tear ruined it
[ __ ] ruin the motels and then you got
to get the insurance claims
I bet dude look the dark arts abound
brother the dark arts are bound but
don't be ashamed of yourself for sitting
down and doing urination you know that's
kind of a thinker stance really that's
that Filipino squat
you know Filipinos they like to sit down
and think you know stand you know we're
and they're smaller targets they don't
get killed as much in war go go think
about 70 or 80 Wars okay think about it
think about 40 it's quicker to think
about 40 wars you don't think about
Filipinos dying do you because you don't
seem let's squat it down they're
thinking very wise beautiful smiling
people better saunas gone divertido
they Boca the people with the phone with
the jointer in their mouths Filipinos
and shout out to my wine I've never make
all Filipino Grigio for the man that
sits down to urinate no shame in your
game brother
drip drop you know be that bad boy be
that bad boy ma'am and I appreciate you
sharing that too and maybe try the
multiplication other guys suggested
that's a good thing I'm gonna try it but
don't feel a shame and I'd do that stuff
too and it gives us a chance to sit and
think and calculate it instead of
standing up there with our nerves you
know we make adjustments we meet the
world where it's at you know because do
for most of my life I stood there afraid
acting like I could piss dude
isn't that crazy like I'm pissed off or
walking bruh
again oh I pissed I didn't I didn't but
the whole time I can't even get that
drizzle drizzle you know I can't I can't
even get that 10% a piss you know piss
you know precipitation
but I just you know I want to keep
living the [ __ ] nobody's watching
that [ __ ] man
get into your comfort zone and if you
got a squatter it out and drip drop to
be comfortable that's okay that's okay
man cuz you make adjustments you meet
the world where it's at
that's how think that's how you get
better that's how you move forward now
you're not sitting there you you know
you know standing there with your hand
and you've jumped you know fake piss him
forever then you got you know you know
he's sitting in a bladder you can enjoy
the rest of the game you got a full
bladder of urine your dad thinks you
hate him because you've got this
uncomfortable look on your face but you
riding on two gallons of [ __ ] you
know boiled Pepsi that's laying in your
bladder it's just a world of [ __ ]
when we when we when we started and we
start it by fear by the fear man
so I appreciate you sharing that making
me think yeah let's take a little stick
in the Wiener world man and we'll stick
with some more Weiner calls that came in
these are all labeled Weiner by my
producer so from here on out I'm getting
into this Weiner category onward hey do
appreciate you appreciate the podcast I
just want to make a comment a few
meetings made a little bit to keep it up
there in fact oh yeah this was a call
that came in last week the man was
calling he said that uh you know he'd
been having issues even masturbating too
much and it was affecting his
relationship with his girlfriend onward
I've actually dealt with that a little
bit before so I think he just made to
kind of find out why he's doing that so
much for me it was because of who I was
with and I found myself going my
extracurricular activities I was looking
for thank you what I I'm sorry but I
lost my train of thought for a second
because I looked at my phone so I want
to apologize and I'm gonna take your
call back and start it over I'm sorry
dude I shouldn't have done it but [ __ ]
honestly I didn't know I was doing it
and then I did it I mean that's like a
witch's spell isn't it this technology
that's a witch's spell and that [ __ ]
ain't illegal bruh this is hand
the [ __ ] hand cocaine sauna phone
that's that faux cane baby let's start
your call again I know is all about
jerking off I thank all my ATO
appreciate you appreciate the podcast I
just want to make a comment a few
meetings made a little bit two minutes
can't keep it up during threat
oh yeah BD Jack and he called in last
week he was having some issues and I
respect him for calling man Jack thank
you for calling dude I know it's kind of
stuff tough stuff to share sometimes you
know but I've struggled with that a lot
of my life you know they used to call me
the soft boss and I wouldn't have that
erection broad but I would have that you
know it's still kind of a choice meat I
had that choice meat you know I had that
kind of skirt steak you know it's not
really you don't know how it's gonna be
served but it's you know it's still kind
of steak you know but anyhow yeah BT
Jack he called in last week and he was
having he was doing too much self
pleasure
you know when creating his own straight
up body oil out the front that you know
that that skeet baby then we need tears
bra them genetic weenie tears that your
weenie makes and your nuts make together
as a team that's teamwork fluid and the
thing was that he he he was struggling
with it
because was a it was affecting his
relationship and that's where we were
with him and now you have called in
thank you for calling let's hear some of
your suggestions for him I'm guessing
I've actually dealt with that a little
bit before so I think he just needs to
find out why he's doing that so much for
me it was because of who I was with and
I found myself going my extracurricular
activities I was looking for potentially
what I craved and I wasn't who I was
with and now I'm with a girl [ __ ]
love and you know I still be my meat but
I definitely don't have any problem
keeping it up
maybe that's this issue I don't know I
don't know him
I just already said and that's what I
dealt with maybe it'll help them well I
loved the way you presented it first of
all meaning presented is this is my
experience and this may not help it may
help I don't know but this is me being
willing to share my experience with you
and you're not accusing him or saying it
definitely will so I love the way you
presented that man and that reminds me
of how to present things to people and
how to share instead of you know direct
really and I need reminders about that
stuff and some you know I don't thankful
you call just now because I really I
think needed to needed that yes
sometimes when you when you you know
when you jerk and you know when you're
jerking off you you know it might not be
because it's you don't know if it's the
right person and I've wondered that too
in my life you know cuz I've struggled
with a lot of um you know I've talked
about this before I was talking with a
lotta you know you know being that soft
boss you know being that again that you
know kind of like uh you ever see a dude
that kind of you know has a cane he's
still cruising bro but he gots a cane
you know that's like Monday you know we
you know he's doing everybody off so we
struggles all you know but he's still
out there flexing brah he's still out
there wearing a crown I've got a chunk
of cheese in his mouth
but yeah and I wonder sometimes well as
just cuz I haven't met the right person
and I'm just like forcing my dick into
this other person I don't want into this
haunted house cuz dude [ __ ] somebody
you don't care about cam that's like
putting your Nicki into a haunted house
man think about that and your dick
doesn't even have any eyes dude at least
if we're in the haunted house we have
eyes we know things are looking at us we
know that clock suddenly you know is a
tick
Hakan with knives instead of clock hands
we know that there there's a mummy over
there and we know there's are bats
your dick is just blind bro your dick
doesn't have a eyes all of its eyes are
feelings all of its smell is feelings it
only instead of five senses that have
maybe I guess they could feel and think
I don't know if thinking's a sense but
it probably only has two feelings dude
out of the five two senses so you put in
a two sense animal into a straight-up
fully haunted house and you expecting
that thing that do work boy come home so
yeah maybe that's a good suggestion
maybe you just haven't met that right
person now that doesn't mean alienate
your girl cuz you said you love her you
know but maybe it just it's not the
correct fit but no matter what I'm gonna
say you got to take the pornography out
of it because I know that the gentleman
mentioned that and um and I'm gonna you
know at that because that's a huge issue
let's take on another call well bye
gotta do something uh-uh
I was probably weird thing to keep
happening to me like throughout the last
consecutively literally this past
weekend up in Gainesville with a loose
ball okay thank you for calling man I
think you said your name was will and
this is at the wind star and I think
that's a casino maybe or something let's
hear more eighty year old lady told me a
dirty joke after I got done telling bad
jokes to this waitress oh when senior
citizens they dude it that is carte
blanche
it's carte blanche devereaux do when you
senior citizen you tell them anything
they'll tell you a dirty joke you do it
a senior citizen you tap them on the
shoulder they're like two dicks walk
into an office
did I say office I meant orifice do
senior citizens love that you call them
about offering them you know home
[ __ ] life insurance or trying to
sell them some fake gold or something
next thing you know to you know a senior
so no lady bra who knows how to work a
phone she'll sing you know freakin top
pick bra you know showing you that
frickin bee
bag there Wildman senior citizens
they're just they're dangerous babies
that kind of know what the [ __ ] going
on but are also really bots starting to
bother everybody let's hear more she
said uh eighty years old my just like my
grandmother talking to me said how do
you know when a woman's not wearing
underwear
oh well grandma I don't know she said
well you look at their shoes for the
damn dress then I was [ __ ] forward and
uh yeah it's about eight years of weird
[ __ ] like that just old people and
soccer moms and introducing me to their
kids it's all very strange and uh I'm
not sure what to just go with the flow I
mean [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know well hey you
know wasa the joy it's fun hell yeah
okay so that was it man look I
appreciate you calling man look I
appreciate you calling hitting the
hotline and being you know brave enough
to share that I don't [ __ ] know bro
life is wild you know life has these
crazy things that come at us and you
know I I think your story to me got wild
at the end you know you kind of Hansel
and Gretel me there at the end you kind
of showed me the woods and then just
left me you know standing there with a
bag of [ __ ] bird seats you know and
all the birds is trying to [ __ ] or
something and I'm trying to chill out
but um but yeah I don't know what the
thing about the daughter you know soccer
moms I don't know where that went but
yeah senior citizens as wild mice to be
careful out there but let them tell you
their jokes man but I'm share with you
you know we don't take care of seniors
in our world and you know this does
bring up as a plate this is the thing it
hits me in my heart and I think this is
something we can work on I think next
year somehow is trying to find some time
to spend some time with seniors in some
way and enjoy what they have to offer us
because a lot of cultures do that in
America somehow we forget about some of
that you know and I think we'll get
infected by it more as other cultures
come into America but uh
and maybe just in my life I'm accusing
other people that but there is a there's
a big thing where we forget about our
old alright let's hear more take another
call hey Theo this is Raceland calling
out of Salt Lake City Utah I have a
comment what's up and I'm coming to Salt
Lake this saw this weekend so I'm
grateful man we got five shows that are
sold out out there we're doing a single
mom man I couldn't be more excited I
couldn't be more excited to come there
and and just share some and just have
people laugh and that's it that's it
we're gonna create some good energy
there and see we're gonna let that [ __ ]
loose into the world baby leave the
windows open dog cuz we fill in this big
bad balloon of the universe's balloon
averse up with some solid laughter and
joy let's hear more I'm one of the young
gentlemen that said he was getting soft
during the frisky time and that he
watches a lot of porn I just wanted to
say to that young guy you gotta quit
that [ __ ] man it ain't good for ya and
although the girls that we see on that
porn they ain't real lookin all these
women don't have the stake to fake ass
fake lips it's just a bunch of [ __ ]
to poison our minds and he needs to get
started it's no-shave November and it's
also no not November Selene ain't
nothing we're not masturbating the only
nut you can take or give is when you
have sex with your woman's and that's
all man he needs to cut that [ __ ]
because it feels better to please your
ladies and not please your ladies and
jacking off in your hand it's addicting
and [ __ ] all of us men got a cut gang
gang have a good day men fight gang gang
stay off that hand bang and we ain't
hand bangers dude this ain't hand
bangers ball out here and I appreciate
that call and that's a good suggestion
for dude okay look I'll say this I've
said this is our Vietnam bruh
this is your Mekong Delta and you wanna
stay out of it this is the you heard of
the dark arts this is the dark parts
baby and don't keep that thing keep it
off of your wayne yeah and that's that's
French for wiener bruh and keep it off
your wiener man
masturbation is killing it's killing us
man watching a pornography is just
killing us man I mean it's fun I'll say
that they got some beautiful you know
people out there doing booty tricks and
all of that and you know they got girls
juggling and he you know he can dirty
skittles and all that off of each
other's crevices and everything but what
I'm saying is this it's hurting us it's
hurting us and it's no nut November man
I'm gonna try to commit to it
dude I look I'm if somebody told me that
on November 1st somebody sent me a text
and I had literally just masturbated at
in my hotel room and I just felt so bad
I'm like damn man Here I am supposed to
be taking care of my nuts and everything
and I'm blasting out into my little hand
hand universe bruh sad it's sad because
you got this virility man you got this
special spice in the world you know a
lot of them some of the media some of
these [ __ ] lonely you know it's a lot
of lonely ass people writing articles
about how men aren't good
you know when it's Alana like I think
there's a lot of lonely women to look
there's been a lot of deviant minute
there's a lot of lonely women out there
who are afraid to admit that they want
to be loved by a man and a lot of them
have been writing articles and I've just
accusing all men or they're not accusing
on them but they're putting out these
vibes and times that a lot of men are
bad and I don't believe that I think a
lot of men are good but I do think a lot
of men have been poisoned
also in not knowing how to treat a woman
sometime you know and so we're all in
this together so I'm saying we all have
a part in all of it and men have a big
part though in our own because it
affects your brain every time you
leaking that a little bit of that you
know
you know that secret white worm sauce
bro you know that smokey okie off the
Chokey
you know you out there blasting you know
you make him [ __ ] little baby say you
know you know you making you know you
did blow him baby salmon butter out
there it's nervous it's not good cuz you
need that in your brain you need that
Chi you need that pineapple hit so but
yeah I was just embarrassed man because
I've been doing it you know and I just
masturbate I was like [ __ ] I'm not gonna
do this and then last night the same
thing I thought I wasn't gonna
masturbate I'm literally sitting there
thinking I'm not gonna masturbate and
then BAM dude like like count jerk
you'll abroad thing just bit me in the
neck and next thing you know I'm out
there finna moan dolphin you know just
out there Huck Finn in myself just you
know just Negro Jim and my own deal you
know what I'm sayin brah you know paint
my own fence you know two beautiful you
know black and white friends out there
touching themselves and that's what I
just turned into is bad so but you
understood shame you know and then I
feel the shame that's the biggest thing
then I started to feel ashamed but and
I'm not saying if you were a young buck
and you out there killing deer still in
the woods it's not did then you go do it
if you could jerk off and every give me
some of these young guys they can
[ __ ] fill up a tire or a car tire you
know to get that triple lay out the
weenie they pull over a [ __ ] [ __ ] them
you know fix a flat
all-4-one splat sorry this is sounding
really like a bad comedy album but but
you know what I'm saying man some people
have that ability and they but if I do
it nowadays I feel bad because I don't
want to be doing it man cuz I want to
keep my Chi I want to keep that you know
we have to retain what we have because
the universe man this tech universe is
making all of us that you know about two
years from now it's gonna be crazy to
even have a you know still have semen
people are gonna be you know throwing
their semen off a cliffs and stuff it's
gonna get weird so some of us got to
hold the line
that seed when we call girl love the
show game game time Philadelphia
what's up Thomas from Philadelphia thank
you for calling I'm gonna use you as an
example real quick man if you guys call
you know and when you do I'm grateful
that you do and I do want you to know
that this is a safe place to call and if
you call try and sit upright or
something you talk so I can hear you
better thanks for calling Thomas any kid
advice you got for a fellow man that are
participating in don't know November or
the see where your thoughts are on it
and it's gotta fit for us doing very
well you know I'll say this if you mess
up you can recommit you know don't be
afraid to recommit this because you mess
up doesn't make you a bad person or
anything like that it makes you human
you know makes you human and there's a
lot of examples out there that you
people aren't allowed to mess up you
don't know how to say something and and
explain themselves or talk about it that
ain't the world I live in and that world
is dying off man a lot of people live in
this fictional world where that it's
accused and you know somebody can't
share a thought or a feeling even if
they're wrong and then humble themselves
and apologize you know I mean people are
really divided on that lady megyn kelly
and I don't give in this isn't a
political thing at all but you know she
you know I don't think what she said was
wrong I think what she said was very
progressive in a lot of ways we can't
share our you know a child can't you
know in person a white kid can't
impersonate his favorite black character
because of stuff that people weren't
even alive anymore we're doing a long
time ago to be racist at
use it feels like what you're teaching
that kid there then then then it's just
it's not about connectivity you know to
me it just feel it doesn't feel right
that's the thing and maybe I don't know
exactly what the feelings of but it
doesn't feel right and of course I'm
just a white person saying it I get that
I get that other people might at that
point of view but if I you know if I
have a daughter something she loves a
black princess or she loves you know
native of um Pocahontas and she can't
dress up like her because it's you know
I don't know then I just don't know if
that's the funnest feeling to be you
know if that's a you can't be her
because she's black you can't be here
because she's Native American mm-hmm now
if somebody's making fun of somebody
yeah but what's their intent you know
and then here was the thing about megyn
kelly she came out and apologized and I
think that you know the [ __ ] with the
network and all that and her agency
dropped or I thought that that was lame
by her agency - let her go you know
trying to save this invisible face and
not be some like if a black woman says
something that they think and they
apologize for us like Eartha a Latino
woman says something they apologize for
it then you listen to their apology you
decide if you think they're sincere you
know I found that megyn kelly was very
sincere you know you let them share
their thoughts but to not let anybody
apologize for self mistake that they
made and maybe it was bigger than that
but I don't care what color or
background or anything someone is here's
the thing that's it's not a sustainable
human way for people not to be able to
apologize when they make a mistake what
do you teach and kill her and then what
are you teaching she should know better
she maybe she doesn't know but you think
all adults just [ __ ] know better
because they're adults
are all adults know exactly what your
idea of knowing better is people have
different ideas what about that you know
a lot of these there's a lot of
Hollywood
want to just work with people that
doesn't want to meet humanity where they
are which is human
we're human man people make mistakes all
the time and those are great
opportunities to learn these are the
things that they taught us these are the
things that I've learned from Hollywood
him from growing up and from being you
know teaching people teaching me stuff
that mistakes are a great opportunity to
learn and then now somebody makes a
mistake or were you that or were they
you know and is a front about it and
apologizes and tries to be sympathetic
or empathetic I don't know which one and
they [ __ ] are just chastise it's just
like man it's not it's just not a cool
place for anybody to not be able to make
a mistake because it's not realistic
that's the thing
it's not realistic and I've never held
anybody to that standard in my life you
know and if I ever have man I'm sorry
you know I don't care where they're from
or who they are what color they are what
they're you know like the other day I
was at home and I heard a kid tell a
racist joke you know some joke I didn't
think it was cool and I told him but I
told him why you know I said look this
is why I don't like hearing that because
this is why and it was cool it was cool
you know but to not have a chance for
and then I listened to the kid and what
they thought you know I said well
somebody told me that at school and I
understand you know and I understand
where they come from I left looking kid
it might not be racist the kid has
learned something somewhere
but at the but adults should be able to
everyone should be able to make mistakes
or even not make mistakes and be able to
explain themselves you know but when we
live in a world where you can't where
people can't have a different point of
not even a point of view but a point of
discussion it's a really strange man and
I'm grateful that we don't live in that
place here and if you ever feel like I'm
acting that way or being that way man
please bring that up hit me on the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and in the meantime
I'll be trying not to jerk off dude and
not be ashamed of myself if I don't but
what tips do I have that's what you
asked about what tips do I have when it
comes to not jerking off do you got a
stealthy electronica at night sexting
and stuff like that I think are being
sensual over text or looking at sex
t-thanks xt things on Tex are you know
even Instagram looking at it or looking
at brassieres in wise to Google you know
rare brassieres and stuff I'd be doing
drugs and googling rare brassieres and
you know different Roman you know
Archipelago type of you know brassieres
from the past and all that is [ __ ] and
you know ancient you know titty covers
and all of that and next thing you know
I'm busting out to some [ __ ] that's 1100
AD so that's one way to stay off of a
note to make it through noon up November
stay off the electronic sexual you know
endorsements because look there's a lot
of companies out there they want you to
their companies do they want you to bust
that's all they are all this sexual what
you know why you advertising a women's
bathing suit at a man and then the next
day you advertising pornography because
the first day they got you thinking
about that in the second a day they got
you thinking about that okay that's the
first thing number two spend time with
people don't be alone if you're alone
all the time didn't nobody jerking off
in front of their friends right
except for Louie Anderson louis c.k
sorry I don't know Louie Anderson that
well but dude honestly brah I'd watch
Louie Anderson jerk off dude it seemed
like it would be exciting he's [ __ ]
entertaining I bet he would make a great
bit about it
and he's a showman I mean anyway that
was kind of I don't know where I went
with that but but um you don't you don't
be alone people that's jerking off is
alone that that mentality of like being
by yourself and being secret and you
[ __ ] you know dealing up a little
batch of hand sauce that's a lonely
event spend time with others interact
with others you'll feel the joy from
others and they'll feel your joy and you
feel a little bit more value to yourself
and I think when you when you feel a
little bit more value you might not go
on of those types of sites third and
most importantly you can get there's um
there's something I have it on my own
phone I'll show you right now dude it is
called like iGoogle right here on Google
hot Lanta breast nudie babies okay and I
got this thing comes up it's called moba
sip mo bi CIP this content has been
restricted for your safety this is an
advertisement I don't work for MOBA sip
okay then another one is called covenant
eyes you can put that on your computer
you give the password to a friend you
know or enemy that's crazy so then you
know if you looking up them you know the
majeure key hitters at night they get a
ping on their phone narrate you know
they might be at uh you know maybe
having a couple waffles or something
over there it you know at Wally's
waffles and then they got a ping and
it's like Oh Randall Randall's looking
up that dark bust and you're like damn
so you don't want that happening you
don't want to be interrupted in
somebody's digestion with your you know
infection so you can you can you know
one way that's called covenant eyes and
mobis if those are two things you can
have and those will keep you from you
know pleasuring yourself it just is one
more line of defense because the
pleasure yourself man you you get the
idea and then you have to act on it and
sometime if you have one more hurdle
even though I hate hurdles dude lame
sport jump over something put a [ __ ]
tiger out there bro you know I'm saying
have somebody jump over you know seventy
thousand snails or something not just a
little piece of you know pipe or
whatever that is plah plexi glad I don't
know what it is but but anyway um but
you have one more hurdle between you
doing that self badge so but those are
my three items Manning good luck out
there
we have two more calls that came in and
and then we're gonna go man I'm so
grateful for you guys and I'm so
grateful for you guys just sticking with
this podcast and staying with me man and
uh you know I'm learning as I go and
that's what we're doing here and I'm
when I'm trying to focus on you know for
me I got a I need to go back to more
meetings and get in more types of
environments where you know it just I
don't want to feel like I'm talking at
people I want to feel like I'm talking
with people and I want to feel like I
can hear really good when I can really
hear others I know that I'm really
connected and so my hearing level has
been a little bit wild in the past
couple months because my life's been
changing man you know my life has been
changing like you know finally after
like 15 years I'm going to places and
people are coming out to see my work you
know it's like you know what I'm living
my dreams in some way and that's scary
to think you know and I'll talk about
that maybe a little bit more next week
because that's giving that's making me
think about a lot of stuff let's take
another call here we go hey Bo this is
Sidney in Oklahoma thanks for calling
Sidney onward I hear you talk a lot
about how like you're trying to not
masturbate and you don't watch porn and
so I thought that you'd be a really good
person to ask this question and I did
find out not too long ago that my
boyfriend had been watching porn behind
my back he does know that I am against
it for my own personal reasons okay so
your boyfriend was watching the
pornography behind your back and that's
really a fun place to watch it I'll be
honest you know that's makes you but
that make it feel more secretive you
know he can't be there front yard if I
can have that screen light up his face
in the front yard and got two raccoons
behind him doing also doing it you know
touching himself and looking at them you
know human breast ohm work when I found
out I did freaked out a little bit and I
you know got really mad at him and it
didn't go well it was an open
conversation and I did find out that
that did cause him to you further hide
it from me and yeah and that's shame you
know and we feel ashamed if we get
busted for
a little bit and then it's still the
only thing that we know how to do to
make ourselves feel good sometimes and
so we keep doing it don't work
partaking in the porn so I guess my
question is just like how do I address
this and let me hear that in part again
sighs I think I missed something Albert
what partaking in the porn so I guess my
question is just like how do I address
this in a way that it's going to create
an open conversation and maybe just like
help our relationship a little bit more
I love him so much and it's something
that I'm willing to work with him on I
just don't know where to start and I
don't want him to close down whenever I
do try to address this subject if there
are guys that have some advice as well
I'd really love to hear it because I'm a
little bit at a loss but you know it's
something I'm willing to work on and
some okay and I appreciate your calling
I mean to cut you off there but I just
you know the episode has been long for
everyone and I appreciate what you're
saying there and I don't want to lose my
thought that I can you know that I can
share my experience and my strength and
hope with you from that you know it's
nice that you care it's nice that you
want to know how to present it to them
because presentation is everything you
know if you present somebody to you know
if you go at you've something that you
know it's like if you show up with your
you know presentation is everything you
can be angry but you can show up with
your hand open man that's that is power
to be angry and show up with your hand
open instead of close breath that's
power and with the open hand you can get
you can get something and what you can
get is somewhere you can get somewhere
when you show up like this
everybody can you know and we I'm sick
of it there's this vibe up there that
only some people need to show up
open-handed know everybody needs to show
up open-handed but with your you know
that I love the fact you want to know
how to approach him and you know yeah it
is shut down it's a shameful thing and
we do it and I and I say we because I've
done this and I do it you know it's a
form of
self-pleasuring our former self-soothe
and i do it at Sue's myself it makes me
feel okay it's one way that i can make
myself feel good immediately you know
and for me those are a lot of feelings I
never felt good growing up and so that's
a way that I can it's a you know it's a
it's almost at this point become a fake
you know it's almost become a drug it's
like a jewel I'm just hitting my jewel
you know getting that that uh that you
know this is such a tacky term but that
dick a teen you know I'm getting that
feeling that I'm getting that that up
hit that makes me feel good and that's
what he's doing you know and he's
probably there's probably some addiction
to it and if you don't like it you know
you can all you can say hey look I don't
really like it out like if you spent
more that time with me you know I like
if you thought of me in those ways and
see how he reacts to it I mean if he
doesn't want to change his ways and I
think for you you got to make your own
decision what do you want to do you know
you want to stay there do you want to
move separately and uh that might not be
what you're looking for you're looking
how to present it to him but if it is
affecting you guys a sex life you know
ask him what he really wants is you if
you know he might be afraid to talk
about something sexually with you my
problems have been if I'm in love with a
woman I have a very tough time marrying
someone that I really care about and
someone that I'm able to have sex with
you know and there's others you know
they call that the Madonna [ __ ] complex
there's a lot of different series of
thoughts around it and you know and
that's one of the things I go to therapy
about sometimes trying to figure out for
myself and get into some of that but
even with therapy someone is just
practice you know in doing a practice
with your partner and so you gotta acts
you know you gotta acts ma you know why
don't we not watch it together and look
and let's talk and be int let's share
what do you like of what pornography do
you like have them sit and tell you it's
gonna be really uncomfortable maybe but
he'll be sharing you know and I only say
that because you know when I've been
asked that I have truffle time even
talking about that kind of stuff because
it makes me feel like a shame to myself
I guess if I share like even sexual type
of thoughts and stuff
and I don't know where some of that
comes from you know it's like I'll be
like perverted on one side of my head
but afraid to even like you know but
like a embarrassed to even talk about
sex on the other side of my head and
maybe that's just whatever affliction is
the saint you know I don't know I don't
know maybe that's just who I am
and maybe that's just how I'll always be
you know I don't always want to fight
everything that I am but for him I would
pretty you know I'd ask him you know if
there's ways that we could spend time
together so you're not watching this and
how it makes you feel that he watches it
you know but make and make sure you know
how it it why you feel that way to not
just I don't want you watching but how
it makes you feel you know and then it
might help him to be able to know that
by not watching it he's caring about you
so maybe if you could present it to him
presentation again that that could
really be something that could help him
let go Wow so then he doesn't think I'm
not you know by not at being addicted or
watching it and I'm actually I'm doing
something positive for my girlfriend
because it's a powerful thing
this [ __ ] is powerful and and I'm glad
that the year on the front lines of
trying to you know help him figure it
out I don't know if that was helpful or
not but but also there's also then you
can go to sex addicts SLA a sex and love
addiction you could ask him to go to
that and go to some of those meetings
and talk about it or just get some of
the literature off the internet and
we'll put the link below in the episode
so you can see that kind of stuff a lot
of meaning going to that thing and sex
addiction doesn't mean you if I'm
running around town and you you know
you're trying to ride every pony even
when the fairs closed down you jump in
the carnival gates to [ __ ] get on top
of this fake zebra or something it means
that sometimes you're emotionally you
just seek out comfort you know you seek
out comfort from people constant
constant comfort and for me you know
I've started with some of that because I
didn't have a lot of comfort as a child
I grew up in a very uncomfortable
environment
and I just never felt any comfort and so
I'll go for the first place I could get
it's like sugar you know anything
emotional that makes me feel good or joy
from another woman and so a lot of times
that would be said you know when you're
young it's comfort you get a little
older a sexual and then when pornography
comes it's just that you can get the
sexual all the time and you get right
there and you just stand on the ledge
just jerking off into oblivion you don't
even realize you're doing it anyway
that's just some I thought something off
any of that help but it's nice that you
love your man enough and you're thinking
about him but with that said we got one
more call that came in and and um
homeward hey man I just wanted to call
and I'm just mmm
it's a regular Joe here [ __ ] whippin
that FedEx truck waiting at my pick ups
& FedEx man and I applause you guys you
guys are Santa's you guys are Santa and
I won't tell the kiddies but you guys
are Santa and y'all are doing a great
job and I think I should do an airline
do some of these airlines are so shitty
spirit you got a dude you don't even
make it you show up just you know the
idea of you shows up somewhere just the
ghost of you showing up half of these
joints FedEx you guys should do an
airline overnight X row if you
guaranteed me I get there tomorrow fight
for me
90 bucks I'm good enough dude I'll jump
on here standing-room-only on a FedEx
dude a a little bit of cigarette area in
the back that brat
Oh word ha just listen to your podcast
I've heard every one of them man I've
called it a few different times and
mm-hmm
I just listen to that one about that
gentleman of Maine that cause enough
said that his wife of 12 years had just
tragically passed away man that hit me
right feels moist man still come
cracking up right now a little bit
breaking up kinda trying to get my words
out his to even talk about I wasn't even
me man but yet here's a year you know
bringing some light to his day and I
mean makes my problems feel so dismal it
makes me feel like I'm [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] Muppet out here broad
getting them getting I'm emo Nemo right
now over my little basic ass problems
and you know I hear his his problem I
couldn't imagine and mmm man chest it's
real touching this isn't the only time
that you got me [ __ ] tearing up out
here boy and your podcast over people's
calls and what you are able to do for
people and man just keep spreading I
love and man is truly awesome what
you're doing now
I just can't emphasize it enough that
you are making a change in people's
lives man so love you girl
keep it up gang man I proceed I
appreciate that that's nice you to say
yeah may is funny because your call I've
been joking around a lot and this
episode in your call like really just
kind of reset me into a place I really
that I think I've been longing a being
for a while now with this you know on
this podcast sometimes you know a place
that I miss and a place of just being uh
you know just sharing feelings you know
and sometimes with this podcast I've
gotten in a place where I feel like I
need to entertain and not just be and
you know we live and we learn and I'm
glad to be on this slope but ah but yeah
man you know that special that you care
dude and you know you're out there now
you deliver and you you know you tearing
up onto those packages you got me
thinking about the beautiful wet boxes
being delivered around the universe by
FedEx you know they should charge it
dude that should be an extra $80 you
know the driver washes the package is in
his own tears a tear emotes emotion
sorry I'm not trying to you don't sound
like a cry guy to me at all in that's
okay if you drip a little you know every
guy we I'm dude I don't cry much but
I'll be a little drizzle bear you know
what I'm saying
and that's sweet of you dude it's nice
because you know what it shows man when
you can feel that way too or for me you
know what I've learned man and this is
something I learned through AAA and
going to these programs and stuff I
could never feel anything as a kid and
things would happen I had no feelings
and now when I can feel something man
and it just shows me it makes me realize
how much I can care about people and
that's and then it blows my own mind you
know and so you you know you and by you
calling this a week later now I'm
listening to this and now I'm thinking
about it and you got me tearing up
thinking about this about just what it's
like for people to care about each other
and to care and you know I got at a
female from that gentleman yesterday and
he said to give him a call and I'm gonna
wait I think next some other calls came
in about the man that had lost his wife
you know and I you know and I don't know
sometimes like you know I get scared
about making a podcast like too much
about like sentimental stuff or not
enough about funny stuff or whatever but
whatever man you know I don't want to be
thinking about that anymore because this
is something that's cool you know I like
this you know I like being able to be
here for a moment where you know you
care and now you're taking some care out
into the world and so now you and do
your [ __ ] the Lera damn Care Bear
you're delivering now whatever you're
delivering who cares whatever it is you
know Zappos or you know um you know baby
refrigerators or something like that a
little you know maybe some you know
stone dolphins or something or little
you know good plastic bird baths or
something that do to music you're
delivering all these things but now
you're showing up with care you know now
you're showing up now you're gonna look
at some mani you know you're gonna see
now you're walking down the street in
some man his what you know you see a
guy's wife it's a wife you deliver to
now the husband's working or something
she's pregnant or something you're gonna
do you're gonna look at her differently
your Energy's gonna be different you
approach her because you heard about
this man that lost his wife you know and
that's one thing man that I like you
know that's what I like to be able to
think about this stuff and I'm glad you
maybe you know you kind of brought this
[ __ ] back up and made me think about it
you know because I want to be I want to
get all there is out of life man as
[ __ ] lame as that sounds to say so
many people sell this [ __ ] they want all
this money and people want to you know
be juggling dime
on their dick and doing all of that and
feeding [ __ ] diamonds to little you
know dolphins that are you know [ __ ]
you know handicapped otters and [ __ ]
like that I want to just feel what it is
man I want to hike these Himalayas
inside of myself and I don't want to
start my own ego and yeah dude it's
amazing man when somebody can care bro
when you fit when you feel how much you
can care for somebody else that man hit
you you know something about his story
you know you heard his story you're like
man that guy cares about his wife here's
what it did for me that guy cares about
his wife so much you know that I wish
somebody would care about me that way
you know and that I wish I would be able
to care about I hope that one day I
could care about somebody as much you
know am i brave enough to care about
somebody as much as that man you know as
much as it sounds like he cared about
his wife you know or am I just gonna
give in to these dark arts all the time
and I don't know sometimes I don't know
honestly if I really asked myself if I
really answer honestly I don't know
sometimes you know if I'm strong enough
to you know get to the promised land
that I know is inside of my heart but I
know that I'm gonna try bro I know that
I want to thank everybody for calling
man you got me leaking out the face man
so I you my dude I uh
I'm Dori um you know or whatever the
other [ __ ] little fish name is the
[ __ ] little handicap trout on that
one you know that [ __ ] you know that
you know that fidgety mackerel or
something the one Augusta you know I'm
the other one but here we are brah and
look do you know what I'm that that the
skeet out of my face Bronx no Knut
November dude I'm bringing it out the
eyeballs if I got to but I'm grateful
man I'm grateful that we are in a place
where men and women can communicate here
we're out here on the front line
when our feelings to be alive we want to
live life we're trying we're laughing
we're not giving up on humanity you know
we're trying to be understanding of
people no matter who they are what color
they are what gender they are you know
even though I still look if I'm watching
a woman try to park bro
don't even pretend I ain't laughing out
of my [ __ ] eyeballs dude don't even
pretend it but thank you man thank you
everybody that called
and uh and we're gonna keep parallel
park in this podcast into a comfortable
place where we can all be and sometimes
the uncomfortable place you know anyway
I've been rambling I've taken up enough
of your time
but I'm grateful to you guys and I love
you and I'm happy to be here and yeah
look we got a lot to be thankful for
it's Thanksgiving it's no not November
we get the Mission Continues we keep
moving along
dude this a beautiful time of year this
is a beautiful time of year somebody's
coming at you Harkin about business and
all that I you tell them man yeah [ __ ]
you got a you know two teaspoons of your
wife's casserole in your jaw you got
your little niece or nephew you know
fully clothed on your arm or in your
hands you know you're feeling good
there's a lot of beauty in the world
look at that you guys be good to
yourselves man you guys deserve it and
I'm gonna try to do the same thing for
me this week and we'll meet up here next
week I think we're gonna have a Thursday
episode this week of a guest but I don't
know yet and I'm gonna try to take good
care of myself dude I'm gonna go to some
meetings and I'm gonna get myself into a
place where I just feel better I've been
feeling irrational we all over the place
but life's been changing some but I'm
grateful and I'm glad you guys are still
here
have a good day man be good to yourself
somebody told me that he was leaving the
comedy show the other night he said man
hey man be good to yourself you know you
probably deserved it
we had some brothers that came out
father and son a guy a dad brought his
son from Rochester he just turned 19
years old
you know and uh and it was special man
and maybe you know I'm looking at the
dad and his son is right there and his
son was so excited and I gave his son I
think it's t-shirt or something you know
one of the t-shirts were coming out and
[Music]
yeah and it's like I you know I my dad
never got to do anything like that for
me my dad never even got to see me tell
a joke you know and uh but I get to live
vicariously through their moment you
know through this dad and his son you
could tell they're just you know that
they care about each other and I get to
live like I get my I get one moment with
my dad right there through those two
guys I get that because he did it you
know cuz the dad said to their the son
said it whatever the dad recognized the
syle the heat my son loves this I'm
gonna go do this with him then I see it
I'm there right I'm [ __ ] there I'm the
[ __ ] you know riddle Pony I'm to do
schlepping he's freaking dirty riddles
around and I see it and they're like
they're so excited you know he's telling
me you know I'm his son's favorite
comedian or one of he included a couple
of other guys who were great so I
respected his son's point of view
comedic Lee but it just but they don't
Roz what they did for me you know I get
one moment of a moment I never had with
my dad I get that through them I get to
see that I get to see that you know
whether
I did that you know through the heavens
inside of me or you know my higher power
did that he wants to show me that like
hey you know like you know your dad's on
a lie but you can still feel the same
exact feeling you would have with your
father my higher power saying I can show
you that feeling right here with two
other people so it almost has double
beauty because now not only do I get to
feel it but I get to see somebody else
have it you know so I get to like I
don't know I can't explain myself fully
but that's okay I never have been able
to
[Music]
let's good song I'm just sitting on your
front porch wondering how could I be so
far and my mind is somewhere else but
when I found it I'll patch up where it's
been thank you guys so much man I uh I
really needed this today
[Music]
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
then moving way too fast let's keep it
going
ahead a little
that's Bishop gun I'm telling you right
now I just want to I just want to live a
life worthwhile don't you feel that
sometimes man that's how I feel you know
I just want to just give myself the
comfort I know I've always really really
wanted you know I don't know what that
means I don't know why what I'm talking
about
[Music]
we sing it Travis as Bishop Gunn ladies
and gentlemen it's okay to love him man
that man is [ __ ] damn beautiful bro
you look at him from certain angles you
look like a woman
[Music]
we got this guy's
don't be afraid if you feel good don't
be afraid to take that [ __ ] feeling
into work they'll be afraid to take that
feeling into your family you need a in
this world we feel good and we're afraid
to take it out into the world we're
ashamed of [ __ ] feeling good man I
don't I don't want that and I'm not
yelling at you I'm yelling at me I'm
tired of feeling that way I'm tired of
getting all excited in my car when I
hear that Bishop gun and then I get out
and put on this different face for the
world let them feel the envy let them
get on board why does that man feel good
I want to know why you know I want to
know why you guys be good yourselves man
you probably deserve it I love you and
thank you so much maybe this is the most
selfish episode I've ever made but you
know sometime you got to take one for
the team dude even if you didn't even if
you're the only one that's playing I
don't know I just got a lot out of this
one thank you so much